Hello Freak bitches.
If you're a dude and your best friend is
a woman,
it's,
uh,
it's suspect,
suspect highly suspect.
Yeah.
Unless she's really unusual.
Well,
look,
there are,
and I'm not saying that women and hot
women and whoever are,
I mean they're fucking good.
They can be great friends,
but you all,
if they're hot and even if they're not,
you sometimes still wanna yeah.
Fuck that.
And that's okay.
Right.
You know the guys that do have like a,
a hot woman,
that's a best friend that they're not
banging and they pretend no,
it's just totally platonic.
Okay.
I could never trust that guy unless he
has like an insanely hot wife that,
that or,
or if they used to date,
yes.
That's awesome.
That's possible.
If they legitimately have nothing to do
with each other anymore.
Right?
Like I have exes that like I wouldn't
want to sleep with,
but in their hot,
you know what I mean?
Right.
It's over,
it's over.
But you're still friends friendly and
did not your best shit.
Fucking weird.
That's weird.
What's weird when anybody,
like when a guy is like working in angle
and trying really hard to like position
himself as better than he positioned
himself as being like different than
every other guy.
You know,
there's a lot of guys out there doing
really negative things.
I read this one guy's fucking twitter
page other day.
It was amazing.
It was just like he's.
He might be the ultimate White Knight.
I don't want to give out his twitter
page,
but he.
He might be like the greatest.
If I met him,
he probably has almost no blood in his
veins is blood sugar is probably zero.
He probably faints all day long.
It was so weak.
But one of the things he said is he
said,
he said,
although I still practice feminists,
still practice feminism.
I no longer associate.
I no longer would you say advertise
myself as a feminist because I feel like
it's up to women to decide whether or
not I'm doing feminism correctly.
Oh Jesus Christ.
So I'll still practice feminism,
but I will no longer advertise myself as
a feminist.
Jesus Christ.
That's A.
I actually don't even know what to say
about that.
And then I got,
I started playing in a rock band and my
20th century I didn't do much martial
arts at all.
After you,
did you practice music before that?
Like when did you get involved in music?
Was a growing up as a kid,
Bruce Lee and Alice Cooper are like my
two Glam rock came from the makeup and,
and a late mid twenties I started
playing in a band and I really liked
performing and I did a lot of jumping
and kicking and wearing tight pants and
you know,
and David Lee Roth.
Exactly,
exactly.
And uh,
somewhere,
but you and David Lee Roth in the New
York dolls know very drunk,
very,
very fucked up like through the whole
era.
Like we would go and we.
Oh Man.
And I told Eddie this story.
I haven't told a lot of people this
story,
but people ask me about it.
My friends ask me about it recently,
but I was basically on tour.
So I do that for like 10,
12,
14 years and we're touring England in
the UK.
And um,
and uh,
like uh,
Italy and a few places like that we did
really well over there and I had a
seizure from just doing so much drugs
and drinking so much and like a bad,
like you basically I had been,
when I came back the doctor said the
vodka and red bull was actually the
biggest component.
The fact that I took a lot of speed over
the three days without sleeping,
let me drink more vodka,
red bull.
But basically as the sugar leaves your
body,
it goes down and you and you get sick
and when the alcohol then leaves your
body,
it draws more sugar and you have a
hypoglycemic seizure.
So I've lived laying on the couch,
I felt terrible for like 10 hours and
then all of a sudden apparently I just
yelled something and people came over
and I felt this electricity shooting
down my arms into my hands and they just
locked up and I rolled back down.
My eyes rolled in my head.
I thought it was 10 seconds later and
everyone's looking at me like I just got
knocked out,
you know?
And then apparently it was like a minute
or something and I went back and the
doctor said,
dude,
you got to get your life together.
And I started training martial arts
again pretty much that day.
And then I trained,
you know,
three times a week,
then five,
then seven,
then I was doing Jujitsu Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday 7:00 AM noon and 6:00 PM and
Tuesday and Thursday noon and 6:00 PM.
And wait a minute,
you were training Jujitsu three times a
day.
Three times a day.
Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday.
Twice a day.
Tuesday,
Thursday for about six months.
And then people kind of knew me a little
in Canada,
like on television doing stuff.
I was like a reality show judge.
And the network said,
Oh,
you're going to fight.
Well why don't we do a TV show about
that?
Wow.
And that kind of allowed me.
I really want it to be in the fight
world.
That's what I love the second I kinda
had,
you know,
been not living a crazy lifestyle.
All I wanted to do his martial arts.
And then real really from that minute
on,
that's all I kind of did.
And that's all I was interested in.
How did you get started rapping you do
you,
do you consider that rap kind of started
off in spoken word.
So I started off,
just kind of spirals into hip hop.
And again,
a lot of people who've spoken word and
shit basically in poetry,
but it was exactly the same.
Um,
spoken word has potential.
We would have people like being.
People love.
I have a dream.
I have a dream is God damn spoken word.
I mean Martin Luther King's I have a
dream speech was referred to as spoken
word poetry because that's the most
literal tsunami.
A really an intricate stemmed upset.
That's one piece.
That's a whole story.
That's a spoken word.
Does this word poetry is poet.
Does that have a bad connotation?
Like a pretentious kind of think?
You're
right.
You say,
I remember I was at the comedy cellar in
New York and David tells on stage and
he's killing and there's this snotty
fucking the audience.
And for some reason the guy took offense
to want to Dave's jokes and says
something.
And,
and Dave's like,
well,
I'm sorry sir.
I'm just trying to.
You're trying to do some jokes.
What do you do for a living,
sir?
Now he's fucking.
The guy goes,
I'm a poet,
published and I'll never forget that
there for a year.
I would say that to people.
I'm a poet,
published,
like trying to get insurance and shit
like that.
I'd just try and explain what I do and
then just go with unemployed or self
employed because they put poetry on my
thing.
This,
I'll never forget that asshole.
I'm a poet,
published and he had like fashionable
clothes on shit,
you know,
just totally lives at home still with
his mom.
Dave attell doesn't even remember it,
but I remember it.
It wasn't even me that got heckled.
Fuckheads.